Sáng 18, tập đoàn sân rút hợp hợp dự án nhả hát Opira Hàn Nội và công viên văn hoa
nghệ thuật truyền đề tại khu vực hồ đầm chiếc.
Bánh đạo quang án, quận tây hồ, quy mô mùi chiến hách ta,
tổng vốn hơn 12.5 tỷ đồng.
Dự kiến hoàn thành 50.5, đây là công trình trọng điểm trong bình bệnh miếm 1 năm ngày dài phóng thủ đô.
Dự án hồ nhá hát hiện đại, đa năng và công viên truyền đề thảo không dàn sáng tạo,
vui chơi, suy định văn hoa.
Nhà hát sò kiến chúc xưa ý tà liên rên dô biệt nô thiết kế,
tổng dịch sản khoảng 40.5, có hai khán phòng,
Opira khoảng 40.5 tỷ đám chăm chỗ và khán phòng đàn năng hơn 40.5 tỷ đồng.
Cung các không dành vụ trở.
Dìm những là máy vọng lấy cảm hứng viên nọc trai nổi trên mạnh nước,
tạo hiệu ứng phản chữ theo án sáng,
theo phó chủ tịch i bán nhân dân thành phố hàn lỗi dương đất tấn,
dự án phục vụ cộng đồng.
Không bị lợi nợ, sự dụng mỏ chăm phần chăm bố xa hội hóa.